okay welcome to today's webinar so you
have a business idea how to create a
compelling business for you and your
stakeholders it is my pleasure to
introduce our featured presenters today
michael lepic is an associate professor
of civil and environmental engineering
in the stanford engineering school
he is the faculty director of both the
stanford center for sustainable
development and global competitiveness
in stanford's new smart city research
center in songdo south korea
he is also a senior fellow at stanford's
woods institut
institute for the environment he studies
the multi-scale design construction and
operation of sustainable and smart built
environments
mike lyons is managing director of force
12 ventures and an adjunct professor of
civil and environmental engineering and
management science and engineering at
stanford university
he's a serial entrepreneur who founded
over 10 companies
including integrated systems rti.com
westlight ai
sciatic incorporated mike has been a
general partner at five venture capital
funds including co-founding general
partner at zilka venture partners
he was also a founding adjunct faculty
member of the stanford engineering and
entrepreneurship program
mike holds degrees in engineering
physics aeronautics and astronomic
astronautics and business administration
from cornell
and stanford and pepperdine university
pedram mo creon is driven by reimagining
how digital technologies will help
address the challenges of global
urbanization
he is an adjunct professor at stanford
university and a lecturer at the haas
school of business at uc berkeley
where he teaches and advises
entrepreneurs and global 1000 companies
alike on the topics of entrepreneurship
business model disruption and technology
innovation strategy
he was previously a principal at
mayfield one of silicon valley's most
storied venture capital firms
and is a founding partner of the ratio
academy new line ventures and
an entrepreneur in residence at general
electric
and with that i will turn it over to our
speakers
uh i wanted to start with our one of our
uh frameworks specifically the
opportunity assessment uh
opportunity assessment framework and so
you know it
it starts with that business opportunity
and we said that was the first component
that you really have to hone in on
and that's a product or service around
which you can build
a profitable business and generate a
positive return to all of your
stakeholders
and and one of the questions that we
want to help you answer very early on so
that we don't waste a great deal of time
engaging in ideas that really aren't
going to be a profitable business
and generate a positive return is to
engage in
opportunity assessment as pedram had
said is there a quote there there
because if there's not let's move on and
and so i'm going to ask um
pedram and mike to sort of walk through
uh
in detail the the opportunity assessment
framework not too much time
but um kind of walk us through um the
the various stages of opportunity
assessment framework and it
and it's set up sort of as this
honeycomb so um pedram and michael i'll
turn it over to you and just let me know
when you want me to advance some slides
sure um so this this framework
um my clients and i have been teaching
our regular stanford class
uh in entrepreneurship for quite some
time and and mike has been teaching it
for an order of magnitude longer than i
so so a lot of the things i've learned i
basically said learn from him but we
were sitting there a few years ago
saying look there's a lot of different
frameworks and a lot of different
canvases that are being used out there
but some of them are trying to get into
the details too quickly
how do we elevate the conversation at
the beginning
to really start to focus on what are the
most important questions that people
should be thinking about
as they're starting this journey of
thinking about a new venture
and again this is not just about
startups right this is about a new
product this is about a new initiative
this is about a new
um plan of doing something you can apply
this
basically simple simple framework to a
whole variety of things
that convey this notion of thinking
about an opportunity
and the realization that we had is if
you actually boil it down
um there's really only six questions
that we
we as human beings at least in the
english language can understand right
which
is why what where how when and who
so why not just apply those and to see
if those are going to be the the sixth
simplest most frames of thinking about
an opportunity
that we can apply and then really
thinking about
what did each of these things mean in
an individual context around a framework
that we could use to then think about
opportunity assessment
and so we'll go through the six
different boxes here but i want to make
sure that if there's something that mike
wanted to add to this
high-level concept um that we we do that
too
yeah thanks bedroom um one one thing
that's very important to understand here
is this this looks simple right gee
six questions yeah what that we can do
this is easy
um unfortunately it's not easy and
answering
these six questions in a in a manner
that's thorough enough
to really evaluate the business
opportunity can be
quite non-trivial and take quite some
time actually
um you know we start out with with why
what
where is the problem or the what's the
objective of the business
uh what is the customer's need this is
super critical to understand this and
then
notice also the the top three questions
the top three
boxes in this picture constitute
the major reasons why cor startup
companies
don't make it and uh the first one which
we're going to get into in a minute
is the why what thing which is product
market fit
and the other one is who's the team
who's doing it
and who's trying to execute these
businesses and
it's easy to show through statistical
analysis
for for decades of startup companies
that the product market fit and the
people executing the business
constitute the primary reasons why the
business didn't work
and and so really getting your hand
around the the top of this diagram
is is quite important the things on the
bottom side of this picture
are ones that we control or have more
influence or sorry less influence over
than the top the ones on the top of the
picture and so
we need to understand them in great
detail
but the ones on the top of this picture
we directly
control you know lions it was it's funny
you say
it looks simple but it's not hard it's
kind of like uh you know the theory of
relativity
looks simple it's actually quite
complicated
yeah right and and so in order to
understand some of that complexity
um uh let's start to dive into each one
of these specifically so
the why the customer need
pedram so the the customer motivation
is the the essence of why a new venture
would exist right
and it's it's really answering why
why are you even spending time
doing something and it's it's really
important because
there's a lot of times especially from
from a technologist's perspective which
actually all of us on this
and on our side here that mike mike and
i are all engineers
um sometimes from a technologist's
perspective you fall in love with the
solution
too quickly right you've got your
favorite shiny hammer and you think that
this is going to be the thing that saves
the world
but you failed to put it into the
context of whose problem are you
actually solving
and so the customer motivation is
basically the anchor
um that we begin with and this framework
this literally we're just walking you
through
uh elements of the first module that
that is part of this course right now so
this is actually
material directly from from the from the
course itself but as you notice
and to to michael epik's point these
questions are actually somewhat
complicated
um and and they're not necessarily
trivial things to answer
but you need to think about them
holistically before you start to get
into the details of thinking about
designing your business model and
designing your solution
outright so the whole program is really
designed around
giving you a first pass-through of this
initially
making sure that there's something that
holds together sufficiently that's
anchored on this customer motivation
and then spending more time and more
cycles really delving into the execution
frame
once we've defined the obviously the
customer motivation we start to think
about the solution and this is what my
clients were speaking to
product market fit this is the thing
that every single
organization whether in silicon valley
or elsewhere
is dying to get into is that zone of
product market fit
when you think about an existing big
corporation they're
operating inside of that product market
bit zone if you think about
a three-person startup with an idea
they're aspiring to get into this
product market fit zone
and we're gonna unpack that as part of
module two but
just so that everybody understands what
we're really talking about is
a a market need um a
a source of opportunity that is really
driven by somebody outside of your your
core group
that is then managed by a solution that
you know directly and and explicitly
addresses that market need and that's
what we start to think about from the
solution perspective
unpacking this further when we start to
think about the market
the market is really where all of these
people that have that problem sit
and this is where we start to think
about you know where are they located
how many of them
are there how do we reach them um
how are they organized um you know
how much are they spending on other
stuff it's really starting to then think
about the nuances of that
we don't want to think about a market
immediately because
a market at large doesn't really have
a problem people inside of that market
have a problem
right and even an organization it's
people inside of an organization that
have a problem
if you're going to be a a b2b or
business to business type of
of operation so we always want to anchor
with
the individual with the why with the
customer
wrap that around what we think is going
to solve their problem
what we think about in terms of the
broader context of how many are there
and is there sort of a big enough
business for us to build
then we unpack it into the how which is
the business model
and the business model is really just
focused at least in our parliament
around the mechanisms by which you
execute on product market fit
that's all it's really thinking about
how are you providing value
and how are you getting rewarded for
that value and who else is involved in
that process
to mike lyons point this is typically
has to do with understanding the
structure of the ecosystem that you're
participating in
because you don't really control the
overall ecosystem
you can only control a portion of that
so you want to think about the stuff
that you can control
being applied inside of a business model
that is relevant to make sure that your
product and your solution gets into the
hands of the right customers in the
right way
the next piece of it which is sort of
the the timing is again something that's
completely out of your control
but if you think about a lot of good
companies
they were sort of there at the right
place at the right time and so what we
always want to do is make sure that you
understand the context of time for your
opportunity
are you too early are you too late and
how do you justify the fact that
now is the right time to do this at
least from your perspective
because it's going to be a huge factor
um an uncontrollable one that you're
going to have to manipulate and maneuver
around
before your idea comes to life and last
and certainly not least
we get into the who piece right arguably
the who
is the the source of all of success
and most of the failure that a startup
or any type of initiative has
and this is the piece of it that mike
lyons was speaking of of in terms of the
the three most important elements what
problem are you solving how are you
solving it
and who's on your team that has the
requisite capabilities
now we're not trying to become a
recruiting firm here and try to get you
know the right people
into being part of your team but we just
want to provide you with the right frame
to understand
you know where are your critical
bottlenecks where are the
elements of your existing execution
organization
that is lacking that needs to be added
onto
and that you can then afford to
basically bring on
to help you execute this so these are
basically your blind spots from an
execution perspective that we want to
highlight
and make sure that you're well-versed in
terms of being able to identify the
people that you will need to bring on
to help you execute this um mike lyons i
know this is one of your favorite
topics i don't know if you have any
additional thoughts on this
on this piece is it released drag it out
because we'll run out of time here but
the the team dna
when you put together a new company is
incredibly
critical and it's really
easy to get that wrong i i wish that
weren't so
but i i've made enough of those mistakes
that
i still remember them and
you and you know when you have it right
and
because it's going to drive the culture
of your company and
all kinds of other things that you
can't even imagine how important they
are
and and this is this is one of the major
reasons that companies don't work as
the team wasn't put together in the
right way uh
and you know it when you see it
right well and so and so hopefully
everyone this
idea of the kinds of frameworks that
we're talking about that that are
that are really part and parcel of the
whole one course
um again and again we're going to be
providing
simple easy to understand frameworks
that ask
very tough questions and will force you
to
hone your uh your ideas um
and and hone your execution and hone
your strategy
within this crucible of entrepreneurship
and innovation
you know talking about the team dna and
wanting to make sure you have the right
team dna
um you want to make sure that if you're
going to do a an entrepreneurship
program
you've got a team dna of people you're
learning from that are the right
types of folks and so you know the the
the speakers that you'll see
in in this program uh include yes myself
um as academic director um uh pedram
and mike lyons as as long time
instructors here but also a range of
silicon valley uh luminaries um
uh and and practitioners from all over
the world who have built companies
who have done this and are providing
their deep experience
and expertise so so why i2m
and why now um and and we think there's
there's there's four simple reasons for
this
first the comprehensive approach right
we had talked before about
you want to have both the the sort of
like the creative approach
trying to decide what you want to do but
also the tactical approach coming
together
to say we're going to allow you to build
what you want and we're going to help
you get
it across that finish line it's
experiential
we want you to bring your own ideas
we're not going to sit there and just
say hey
you should work on this idea or this
project we want you to bring
your own ideas and work on them this is
not about a huge opportunity cost
of leaving your current job or leaving
your current company
we want you to do this with the ideas
that you're bringing from your current
job or from your current company or the
startup that you're currently working on
and experience this journey with us it's
foundational
as i mentioned these types of frameworks
that we're presenting
are agnostic to geography
to sector um uh you know the opportunity
assessment framework that that
that we went through it's these you know
six basic questions
that truly are agnostic to either of
those and so we start with foundational
concepts
and then help you build off of them for
true learning
and finally it's practical uh we we
don't want to get
you know mired in the theoretical
business strategy discussions
uh you know yes those those are
important concepts and we build off all
of them
um but we want to help you develop a set
of tools um not not uh not not a set of
thieves
before we get to q a here um any last
comments uh
from you uh mike lyons or or pedram on
on the overall why i2m and why now
so i think you did a great job of just
explaining that the context of this
program
and we really just built this program
because we want
people to go through a journey
whether it's with their existing
projects or
something that they have a passion about
that they want to take to the next level
or just to basically be exposed to the
type of thinking and the types of
questions that they would have to have
in mind as they think about
creating something that is sustainable
um be it a startup
be a project be it a new initiative
inside of a company
but sort of having having a structure
that allows for that
sustainability going forward um
requires a lot of fitness it requires a
lot of thinking and it requires a lot of
planning
and so the the idea of this program was
that we could have just basically done
one piece of this at a time but we
really wanted to
stitch it all together so that um an
individual can actually get it
and gain a broad understanding of all of
these concepts
and then wherever they feel like they're
uncomfortable or they need to learn even
more
there's a myriad of courses that are
also offered at stanford they can
actually provide deeper dives
into every one of the topics that are
presented here
so we think it's a really exciting
opportunity
so so so uh you know as the entrepreneur
in me would say
why now why not now so
um with that i'm gonna i'm gonna hand it
back to hana to uh i know she's been
curating a number of questions that have
come in during the webinar
uh that uh that hopefully we can get to
so uh hana
hi everybody yeah so we have a few
really great questions
um first being what goes into a
successful product market
fit how much confidence can you have in
it
pedram i'm going to throw that to you
because you can explain the
product market fit venn diagram that we
use in i2m
um much better because we have a very
formal framework for this
we do actually the all the priority of
module two
is devoted to this
complicated concept and and to be honest
with you um
even that's not enough to help uh unpack
all the nuances
but the way that we think about this
venn diagram as mike was pointing out
is we think of product market fit as
being the universe of
all the different problems that you can
solve for right that's basically the
market component so what are all the
different things that you can actually
do and solve then we want us then think
about the
the portfolio of products that you can
create that can solve those problems
right
and if you think about that intersection
that's really where we start to get
into that focus zone right so you don't
want to solve too many problems or build
too many different products right so
that's that sort of mentality of
thinking about like an mvp
and a minimum viable market segment
which which we'll describe in the
program
but the the other element of that which
basically makes it an even more
interesting venn diagram is that we also
then want to overlay on top of that
your execution capabilities because you
may not
understand the market problems right
that are relevant you may not have the
right sets of
um solutions or product capabilities to
build this out
so we want you to think about sort of
the three-dimensional venn diagram where
it has
execution product and market and that's
really where the the strongest
organizations and startups
live and the element of team that mike
lyons was talking about
really formulates that bubble that that
we're talking about in terms of
execution
and so what we want you to do is to try
to complicate complicated construct
but to think about it as being also the
mechanism around which you can
focus all of your attention all of your
resources
as you're launching this initiative such
that you have
it as a filter around all your
activities right so all the things you
can be doing um
should turn into you know the few things
that you should be doing
right and and understanding where is it
that you need to then expand your team
such that you can then execute on those
extremely well
so the devote effectively an entire
module to talk about product market fit
um and it's a brilliant first question
yeah and and and as and as you're
getting a sense of
uh this program frameworks frameworks
frameworks and
and and to get to the second part of the
question on confidence the way we can
give you confidence
we can't give you certainty but we can
give you confidence by giving you
well-structured approaches
to think through these very complicated
questions
so on that next question
so a little related to this how can i
make sure my idea
is suitable for the market with all of
the fluidity going on
right now lions do you want to discuss
market uncertainty and fluidity as far
as uh
product development yeah there i mean
there's really
no substitute um for
um customer development and and
going out and engaging uh with
with customers and even now with
increased fluidity
uh and kovid 19 impacts and things of
that nature
you know actually new businesses are
getting a lot of traction
uh these days you know anytime you have
a situation like covet 19
it has problems of course but
it also creates opportunities and and
there are a lot of new opportunities
being created
right now but there's no substitute for
talking to
the customers what their problems are
and
developing relationships with these
folks in the ecosystem
if you do not do this then
achieving product market fit is unlikely
and
you it can't be i guess overstated the
number of cycles you have to spend doing
that
this is not building companies is not an
armchair activity
where you read a few books yeah kind of
think about a little bit
and write up a business plan and say
yeah we're good to go
that will not work and uh the the level
of detail required to
digging into actually figuring out how
to solve
real customer problems in effective ways
um is is a real key to actually
creating anything successful hard work
well i guess the only thing i would add
to that is within the opportunity
assessment we specifically said
trends have to be part of your
assessment and so
we have fluidity part and parcel
to the thinking process in our in our in
our program
so um uh i think that's the way that
that we have to think about the fluidity
and uncertainty
it should be core to your thinking not
something you're like well i wonder how
my
pro current product my current solution
can address that fluidity so
hannah next question yeah
so i have a question saying my partner
and i have at least
10 great business ideas that we think
could be game changers
how do we prioritize and focus these
ideas
considering timing is also a factor
yeah so um in that case for a program
like this
we're gonna want you to come with a
number of those types of ideas um
for you and your partner and then we're
gonna walk you through that business
opportunity assessment
and that gate one pitch right and and
and while doing that
you will hone down to a few um uh
of of those 10 i can guarantee you that
the majority of them are going to fall
to the wayside and say you know what
there's one part of this opportunity
assessment that simply
it doesn't pan out right now for this
and so then it comes down to designing
between those those
those those last couple and and that's
where the coaches
uh and and the and and the faculty
involved with i2m can
can help you do that and and so it's
really about applying the frameworks
early on to get down to that focus focus
focus focus
and then scale uh and and build that
um so uh next question on
we're gonna try to answer these pretty
quickly so we can because i see a lot of
questions coming in
um and uh we'll just try to get to as
many as we can
are there any niche businesses that fall
outside the scope of the opportunity
assessment framework
pedron no
[Laughter]
um least none that we've found because
because
to be honest with you the the framework
is just about asking questions right
and so um it's it's one of those things
where
the the framework is designed to to ask
the the tough but more critical
questions
but not a pointed way that basically is
is limiting you to think about one
particular type of company
um and and the entire program um
we tried as best as we could to kind of
maintain
that high-level view all the way through
so whether you're talking about
a for-profit a non-profit a
business-to-business type of opportunity
a business consumer type of opportunity
um you know just an initiative a lot of
the frameworks are written in the
conversations that we have should be
broadly applicable
um in some cases you know a question
that we may ask you and
may be trivial and you can kind of skip
over it but but there's you know
our belief is that there's no such thing
as the wrong question to ask so
in particular the opportunity assessment
framework is designed to basically
um address that at the highest level
right
if you had some business where you had
no customers they didn't need a solution
there was no market but yet somehow it
was a business maybe this doesn't work
but i don't know what that is
so this participant says i have a
risk-averse mindset
could you talk a little bit about what
the program offers to address that
um um uh pedram would you do
do you want to talk about um gnw or
or uh or at least that those two things
yeah
yeah absolutely so so it's such a it's
such an
interesting conversation it's it's not
explicitly um
addressed here i'm actually one of our
speakers in this program
um a close friend of all of ours uh
paris delatraz
um has some research around risk
aversion and how to think about risk
averse mentalities and the reality is
his research has basically concluded
that that people have two different
um types of risk aversion one is the
risk aversion in their private life
and the other is risk aversion in their
um
corporate or or work life right so so
that hence the ps and the w's is how he
he phrases these and the thinking is
that just because you may be a
risk-averse person
in your private life it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
then
take all those characteristics and apply
it into the business setting as well
so you know he sort of famously talks
about an example like a steve jobs where
where his
his private life is extremely
conservative
but in the business world he's extremely
risk seeking
and then on the other side of that you
have these folks that are accountants by
day
and you know nights and weekends they're
basically you know
rock climbers and and you know uh
parachuters and
all kinds of different things so what we
definitely want to do is to say
we're not necessarily going to help
shape that because that's something that
is sort of ingrained with you
um to some extent but one of the things
we want you to realize is that
this risk aversion also that you may
have
um should not necessarily be viewed as
being a block
towards being a creative and
strong contributor to an entrepreneurial
endeavor and the the only way you do
that is to basically having
sufficient exposure to all the different
questions and all the different
challenging things that may come your
way
um especially at least you see you know
what's the worst that can happen to you
and hopefully that'll start mitigating
some of that you know risk-averse
mentality
but one of the things you had mentioned
a word you had said was exposure
right and so if you want to think about
risk aversion right you have to think
about
you know hazard and exposure right and
if the hazard is lower
you should be open to more exposure and
one of the things
that we try to do in this program is
give you the frameworks and the
structures and the tools
to reduce the hazard right to to to make
it
less of a a um an issue
that you'll have the confidence to
succeed and so therefore you should be
okay with taking some of this risk
because we're here to help you through
that and to walk you through it
so absolutely um anna
when is the right time to think about
fundraising
mike lyons you've done a lot of venture
capital funds and raised a lot of money
for companies
when do you think about fundraising
mm-hmm
well you you you start thinking about it
uh fairly early in the process of as as
you go through this program
in silicon valley in silicon valley you
start thinking about it when you're born
right
i'm kidding yeah but
it's it talked about dna but no
this this program is is really
engineered
to help you with that question uh
you you really aren't ready to
brief investors or to present any kind
of coherent plan to them until you've
actually
tried to lay out milestones and work
through
where you're actually trying to go what
resources you're going to need to
execute the business
and then actually mock up a simulation
financially of what it is you're trying
to do which forces you to make all kinds
of
really interesting assumptions that you
might not have thought about before
and and allows you to think about the
business financially and at that point
you're in a position to actually
articulate
to investors what it is you need
and why you need it and once you have
that together
that informs very strongly your
fundraising strategy and then you can
say ah
okay here's how we're going to do it
because
then you know when to raise money and
how much to raise
until you go through that process which
we'll bring you through in this program
you really don't know the answer to that
question uh
and and you have to get into the details
to answer it
yeah so i think the short answer is
after taking i2m
so with that with that i'm gonna go back
to hana i know we have lots of questions
coming in
but i know you have a couple of uh final
housekeeping things to do
uh before before we wrap up this webinar
so um so hana i'm gonna throw it back to
you
yeah so we have time for i think one
more question
um and i'm gonna go with you mentioned
how critical the team dna is
what advice do you have on assessing
whether you've got the right team
in particular the co-founders
pedro
and keep it quick this is a really easy
question
it really it really comes down to really
understanding what it is that you're
trying to do
and if you feel like the folks that you
have around the table are the ones that
can actually execute on that
um the best and to be honest with you
it's it's more about a mentality thing
than anything right is is there is there
a harmonious um opportunity to actually
work with people that
are like-minded in your approach that
are like-minded in terms of how you're
thinking about building
building out the business and the
opportunity that you're that you're
chasing
and and really just to make sure that is
your
uh i'm gonna use a mic lionism here
right as you're potentially standing in
front of an investor
right are you going to pass the uh the
red face test right
are you feeling like you're confident
enough to say
you know what we know you've seen four
or five other companies that are trying
to do the same thing
this team here we're basically proud of
this team because this is this is going
to be the core team that's going to
execute
and you don't need to have all of the
elements in-house you can surround
yourself with advisors
with mentors with customers that can
help support you so don't view this as
being the founders or the only people
that can actually
do everything um but you but you really
want to make sure that your co-founders
are ones that
um are going to be able to go with you
in the long haul um
and that you can work with and then
there's no um ethical
you know constraints or conflicts that
you might have all right thank you
pedram so with that
i want to thank you all for your
questions and remind you that today's
session was recorded
and a link to the recording will be made
available to all participants within a
week
thank you all so much for attending and
we will send you that
recording as soon as possible
you